It feels very shameful. horrifying even, to
admit but there are times when we may find
ourselves daydreaming about a terrible thing
happening to someone close to us. Deep in
the privacy of our minds, we may feel it would
be a huge relief if a partner or family member
could just vanish from the face of the earth.
They might be run over at a crossing; their
plane might go down; they could contract a
rare and quickly fatal illness (it wouldn’t
hurt at all). It would be hugely sad of course,
but also in certain ways an immense liberation
and relief. No sooner has this thought crossed
our minds, we’re likely to chase it out
in horror – and feel deeply guilty about
our depravity. To put our macabre
imaginings into perspective, the first thing
to remember is how little we know of what
secretly goes through the minds of other people.
We’re aware of our own darkest thoughts
but rarely get to hear those of others. It’s
often the case, therefore, that things will
feel much rarer to us than they are in reality.
It turns out that grim imaginings are very
common. Counsellors and therapists – who
get to hear more of the hidden workings of
other people’s minds than anyone else – are
never surprised when a nice, sensible, interesting
client tentatively reveals an occasional wish
that a loved one would be vapourized. Being
close to someone necessarily involves a high
degree of what therapists call ‘ambivalence,’
a blending of deeply negative and positive
thoughts. When people play an outsize role
in our lives, when they have an enormous emotional
power over us, when our debt to them is immense,
we will both adore and at points resent them
hugely. There will be tenderness and rage;
attachment and revulsion. They can let us
down like few others can, they know our weakest
spots, they enchant but also exhaust us. We’re
not actually going to do anything – of course.
We’re not even taking the tiniest preparatory
steps; we would never buy poison or encourage
them to go cliff-walking on stormy evenings.
But there is relief to be found in the odd
grim daydream nevertheless. Fantasies are
not plans of action. They don’t correspond
to our real values or intentions. They operate
as momentary escapes from powerful feelings.
We fantasise about the death of a loved one
not because we truly want them gone but because
being close to them is such a large and therefore
at times tricky part of our lives. Our fantasy
is a strange but real tribute to the depth
of our bond. The guilt is a symptom that despite
the inevitable and very real tensions and
disappointments of the relationship, we care
about them very much. The meaning of the fantasy
isn’t that we are sick. It’s that loving
someone is never free of frustration. Fortunately,
it’s highly likely that our family member
or partner also harbours similar occasional fantasies
directed towards us and that they too feel
terribly ashamed and guilty in exactly the
way we do. This isn’t monstrosity either,
just further evidence of the beautiful and
surprising subtleties of love.